how long has this been going you guys
been suffering for 3 months smelling my
[__] I'm so
[Music]
sorry welcome back everybody to another
fantastic episode of the careful boys
where we have merchandise that
is hey if this is past the first week of
October check the link in the
description box cuz we got careful boy
merch for you well regardless of October
probably a link in the description box
for you for you brought to you by Takis
it's not brought to you by Takis it's
not we don't know brought to you by Cold
Steel Knives no it's not and J well it
is really brought to you by J more
likely to be brought to you by J there
might also be an ad read on this so that
being
said if you've had more than one job
which job taught you the most
oh the hand job wow
Ken clap please I'm clapping under she's
under she's got a hand job there she's
doing her own jerking herself off over
there oh jeez that was inappropriate
this is a hand job this is the hand job
job of clapping you know what can you
repeat the question cuz I forgot what
you
said what job taught you the most which
hand jobs did you
give if you had CU how much time you got
if you've had more more than one job
which job taught you the most low key
job my first I think my first job taught
me the most yeah what was it what was
your very first job well I think the
biggest like paradigm shift for me was
like my first job right cuz it it taught
you about customer service it taught you
John Rockets do it yeah taught you how
to do something that you don't [__]
like to do like you hated it every day
you're like [__] I don't want to go but
you still put a face on and you show up
and you be professional I think that was
a really big deal for me when I was
18 um and it taught me how to like cold
talk to people cuz I was like really
afraid of doing that and then you just
realize the more you do it it's like
what are you [__] afraid of you
stupid idiot that's what you tell
yourself in your
brain um but I feel like every job like
I think you could always learn so much
at every job that you're at you know
what I
mean that's why we're asking which one
was the most I don't think there was one
actually now I'm talking about it out
loud I don't think there was one that
was the most really cuz they all
different things that you it's all
different yeah but it's all I think
everything leads to the next job you
know like you take the skills from this
job you parlay it to the next one and
you just keep doing that over and over
and over again and I think after that I
just started coaching so then it was
just like learning how to teach and
learning how to be more effective at
communicating maybe complex topics and
trying to distill it down as best you
can and then sometimes you try to do
that and you ramble and you realize oh
this person I'm trying to talk to is
looking at me like they have no idea
what they're talking about and you go
okay well I'll try to fix that next time
but yeah I just
think I didn't answer the question right
I don't
think I was I think we were just all
[__] waiting I don't think I answer
the question right but no point is are
you [__] there is no answer I think
you just
learned the most I feel like every
single job should be teaching you
something and if you don't you [__]
stupid and you're a [__] [__] dude
well the point is to hear something
juicy and entertaining own personal
story is drug dealing a job
sure did you make money I don't think I
don't think it's going to correctly
Inspire anybody in our audience that's
true at the same time that's not true
you're right entrepreneurial Spirit it
is it is feel free to uh teach people
about how drug dealing is useful mine
was yeah mine was actually the Cannabis
company I used to work for yeah that's
legal though what did you learn so much
from it um definitely what ni said
before which is customer how to handle
specific type of customers right High
ones yeah all kinds yeah you're going to
get high ones for sure but also people
who just don't understand it so how to
properly educate that's nice you know
what I mean so how to properly educate
instead of being like no it's not just
something you get high off of you know
what I mean you just got to explain it
to him deeper like you don't have to
smoke it to get high also so like you
were teaching people you taught people
basically you were educating yeah so if
the people obviously have different
opinions on it then fine agree with them
but then also just tell your side maybe
this yeah I get it blah blah blah so
definitely the Cannabis and then how to
make your own opportunity in that job
like how when I was in that cannabis
company I was a shift leader I was just
selling buds all day but then I was just
like I don't want to do this all day so
I want to just do Social Media stuff so
I you know kind of influenced him to
tell them like you guys need a social
media you know and then uh they finally
gave me a position so that taught me how
to just like voice your opinions and
also how the bosses
were um handling business and quality
checking everything so that whole part
was like a whole system I was learning
through was pretty cool that was like
the most job working for Mecca Mid City
oh TI yeah it was a pretty good job
actually and the people how to handle
people
OSHA what do you call it dealing with
OSHA is a big one yeah how to deal with
OSHA and how to deal with uh sexual
harassment and all of that cuz it was
mostly girls there and I was the only
dude so you're like how do I flirt
without getting in
trouble no none of that cuz I know
they're all going to talk but how do I
not talk to my female co-workers at all
that's that's what it is huh just how to
say stuff how to keep it low that's my
thing keep it low there's so many um
girls that work for us a lot like half
of them under age cuz they're high
school so now I'm like now all of my
hiring is like how do I make sure a fox
doesn't come into the little chicken Co
you know protecting your little your
staff yeah cuz we do you know I don't
know it's just it's just you got to be
careful like there was this one dude
that came up to the store looking like
bootleg John B 45 years old but he was
smooth though huh asking if we are
hiring and all the girls were like no no
no no no no like they could smell the
creep off
don't discriminate based off of the way
that they look ladies I was like dude
you could smell perversion sweating off
of his forehead you might be identifying
as a woman and you have to you might
have to oh [__] oh hell
no no Su you dude but it's dangerous
because it's like it's such a good safe
environment and now it's all about how
do you protect that that's yeah yeah
that's important like even how to tell
girls stuff certain things like guys
would be like yo you stink like ass go
[__] take a shower you know what I
mean like I would tell my friends like
yo it's a little onion in here and I
don't stink like that and they be like
oh yeah [__] my bad dog yeah so we had a
girl at work she couldn't smell at all
it's not from Co I think she hit her
head in skateboard or something so she
couldn't smell she couldn't smell so it
was her first day and she's like hey
guys and he was like of just [__]
onion what so I was just like yo no way
and looked at all the girls around me
and I was just like smell that [__] dog
onions like she ate onions or like
onions no it
was B onions it was B onions like Maui
onions yeah s
onions that's what I thought of I like
the sweet Maui onions it was open up the
packed ones and it was musty and I was
just like it's hey first day it's all
good I'm going just whatever happens
right and then it was been a week so far
and it started lingering ah so not good
oh right so hey the girls came up to me
and they're like yo you're the shift
leader you got to take care of it and I
was like what the [__] I'm the only dude
here bro I can't tell her anything I was
like you girls got to tell her like no
we can't we have no we're in no position
to do it they kind of got you there yeah
and I was like you got me so I'm going
to take it to the manager yeah you got
him there yeah and the manager was a
girl so I was like
roof you got to tell her something cuz
like that's unhealthy for our workspace
yeah they're going to be like what kind
of stink weed is
that that's what happened that's what
happened they're like Dam you got some
dck [__]
bro well that's what happened the
customers were like it's not it's not
what I expected but that was like the
best ones we had and they're smelling
and they're likey I don't know if this
is the smell but they were smelling her
that's what it was she like hey check
this out oh
oh went like Spiderman I was going to
say you got to like not be showering for
or something but she said she can't
smell in general oh oh so she doesn't
know she didn't know so what is the
proper way to do it I didn't know so I
had to give it up to the manager and as
soon as the manager talked to her you
came you saw her coming out the freaking
room just cry so she didn't do it the
right way there was no right way what
how what did she say she's like you
smell like [__] you smell like a garbage
can fire D honestly I don't know what
she said but I she came out and rof came
up to me and said see like
why did you make me do it and I was like
cuz you're the [__] manager what do
you mean like I have no position to do
it but that's a hard combo to ask that's
a hard combo to ask honestly my question
is to you guys is how do you say it you
know are you clean or anybody like how
do you say it yeah I would I would maybe
like segue into like like maybe what's
going on in your life you know do need
to be that deep though for a self-help
book like somebody's not showering like
just because she can't smell doesn't
mean she has the inability to not shower
but you know how some people they might
shower but they just got crazy Bo you
know and then there's people that just
have bad hygiene like their idea
showering is like they just walk in and
then they go RSE
clean just feel like maybe you're not
aware
but that's her name oh yeah or they
don't even watch their bed sheets no we'
we've had some stin stink dudes they
just have like stinky life yeah CH and
and and then he told me like he'll get
up in the morning and he's like oh I
didn't do my laundry so even though he
took a shower he would go into his used
laundry basket that he [__] sweated
on put the clothes back on and rush to
work
oh so it's like of course you're going
to smell like Elon
Musk yeah is he smelling [__] I don't
know it sounds like something's going on
for her to not like take care of herself
like okay you're the manager you're the
manager I'm the girl you blame the other
people girl on girl is a little bit
easier you go like hey I'm sorry to say
but a couple of the other co-workers
have said that there's a strange odor
coming from you and stuff like that I I
wasn't there but I just want to make
sure you I wasn't there but I am here
now take care of yourself come back to
work tomorrow the next day and just
smell nice okay that's really you guys
really good I mean you just I can tell
you guys don't have employees this is
what you do did you fart cuz I did it I
didn't okay you farted no you farted you
smell you
smell Joe's like we got a safe
environment and we got to protect that
my God yeah that's what you do you go oh
my you totally farted yes you did don't
even lie dude fart it smells like
onions wait Maui onions but that doesn't
solve it cuz it's just in the moment it
just it's not her solving it for the
next day and the next day in the next
day that's why you got to let her know
that there's a smelling issue so people
are mentioning it so just take care of
yourself come back tomorrow this is what
we did once one time um we had a member
at the gym who would clear out a room
bro like if he trains and he sweats you
could SM like the whole room smelled
that's a tactic he has all the machines
to himself now yeah I can smell ready
and he would come over after he finished
a workout and he'd always wear like tank
tops so he's sweating everywhere and
anytime he would walk into the gym area
and I was in there I'd always pick up a
weight cuz he'd always be like what up
bro like this and every time you shake
his hand you smell it afterwards and you
like oh my God bro so I Pi stank like
that I pick up two dumbbells and he'd
walk by like what up bro how are you I
do that hey what's up dude cool so they
sent the email to the whole gym and was
like hey guys you know make sure when
you guys come train yada yada yada you
are smelling nice you wash your clothes
you have clean you have a couple pairs
of clean clothes when you train and
you're using deodorant and all that
stuff see that's a really good tactic
just a a a broad blast yeah you blast
about but then the problem is some
people don't know it's them and they're
like oh Bell yeah yeah and they just
come hey what's up everybody I feel like
there's no way to like tiptoe around it
you just have to say it stinky people
don't know they stink and also that
email didn't work it didn't work they
like the smell of their own stink or is
it they used to it no they live in their
their stank yeah when you're there the
whole time you're desensitized if you
always smell does it smell if you lived
in a porter potty you probably won't be
able to smell [__] every day cuz I think
talking to the girl is the hard part
because of the more
potential emotional reaction cuz our
stinky person here I was the person that
ended up talking to them who is it I'm
not going to say but other two people
that were running that channel didn't
feel comfortable so I told them I was
like I pull them aside I was like Hey
like this isn't a personal attack or
anything like that um but there this is
the issue and I try to remove it like
not you smell but this is the issue
there's some stinkiness not like you are
the issue and but and then so I'm like
um but it seems like it's where you've
been so is there anything you can do and
he's like oh sh did it get
resolved the next time we shot I was
like hey did your shower and he's like
oh yeah yeah and then I would check in
with the other two does he smell better
like
no I tried
talking that's a hard conversation so I
try to remove it where got use a
sandwich technique where it's not like
your like them stinkman and then the
sniffers I try to remove it from stink
man and the sniffers that's a good B
what if you just a supportive friend
about it like hey come here hey I got
you some
deodorant that's like the same thing of
like handing a piece of gum to somebody
it's like a gift and you go like this ah
look at this rash a
[__] next day I got you some vegan
deodorant those don't work next day
here's a fze bottle let me spray you one
time next day this is a shower yeah but
yeah a personal shower hey I'm sorry
you're fired it's hard man but
especially with the chick yeah see that
was a different one too so I don't know
I've never experienced that and it was
the craziest [__] in my life so did you
ever see her come back to work again
yeah she did but she she her her whole
personality and energy
was cuz maybe her confidence was her
smell so when she washed it away it's
like oh I'm low self-esteem Hey look
that's that's the price you pay by being
a member of society yeah you know what I
mean you subject yourself to being a
member of something broader than just
your own you know but don't you think
odor like that is an easy fix yes if you
could smell it I no some people stin bro
like that's just their natural smell
yeah but there there are still you know
supplements and things that like cuz it
could be a health issue they could be
[__] eating nothing but onion and
dick all day they might have a dead
tooth bro you know hosis you know stin
breath animals when they and people with
dead teeth sometimes they like to get
really close to you when they talk and
you're just like and you feel bad you
feel like a piece of [__] but sometimes
it's just like that's why you got to be
ready with it be like hey you want some
gum yeah I'm going to have a piece would
you like one I'm just offering to no I'm
good and be like I think you should get
one no you
should like that bro I I get Sous cuz I
I know I have bad breath so when I roll
I always chew gum yeah hey remember they
need to bring back B GI says so remember
banaka wait
banaka the spray that [__] tastes so
good but it's so shortlived yeah but
when someone starts talking to you just
[__] shoot that [__] in you just
spray in the vicinity just go uh-huh
hold on all right or go like this you
spray here and then throw it in their
mouth start dude that's so good or just
like you know enforce like human Car
Wash when people walk in to check in for
work it's like FIS spread listerin patch
deodorant wipe you're good to go move on
oh that's smart yeah just making a
protocol dude that's that's tight and
all we doing it because there's cannabis
here and we want to make sure that
there's a unique smell that's
specifically here so everybody need to
be odorless you fixed it dude but then
you're spending thousands of dollars a
day on for Breeze and odors thousands a
day probably just ask chat GP what is
the kindest way to tell someone they
stank yeah but chat gbt don't got
emotions though I wonder what it say but
that's is like tell them they
stink I don't see the problem hey that's
the thing though Chad gbt and emotions
are completely different yeah that's
true especially women's tion I guarantee
you they're somewhere on a form if you
ask what we're not the first peoples
that had an issue with a stanky coworker
well of course there's got to be someone
out there that's figured out a really
nice way to doing it we just don't know
what it is yet cuz for me I would just
fire myself
then I don't have to smell them as the
owner of the business I'm going to ruin
myself I'm going fire myself and collect
Ed you think saying respectfully in the
beginning will help hell no dude imagine
if someone told you you stink I'd be so
embarrassed I feel so bad for them that
they have to tell me that I [__]
stink and two I'd be like how long has
this been going you guys been suffering
for 3 months smelling my [__] I'm so
sorry I'm sorry I smell like a Porter
potty when I speak you know what when
when like a homie or even just like a
acquaintance or whatever has something
in their teeth I'm like hey you got
something in your teeth immediately
right cuz that's like that's what I want
right so I think same [__] right if
somebody smells be like hey you have a
really kind of I don't want to be dis
you have a strange oder about you right
now no you don't say that I would say
that I would have been hurt as to a
friend or to a workplace environment
that needs to be hand if it need if it's
been complained about yeah it's been
complained yeah there's no way around it
you have to if you want to be nice cuz
you smell it you think that you're
experiencing something you're like I'll
just [__] forget it this time and
then it's consistent somebody complains
to you and you're the the manager you
got to do something when you wash
yourself you just have to get in the
nooks and the crannies you got to get in
the carasses well some people okay I
remember my buddy's a tattoo artist and
this he was working on this guy's calf
tattoo right and something smelled like
someone peed their [__] underwear and
left it on the ground like it smelled
like urine and hot
sweat it was sick and we're like where's
that coming from like the ammonia Burn
yeah he knew where that was coming from
the thing is this [__] when he
gets sweaty feet and he had to walk
around the kitchen right the trail left
a yeasty stank smelling oh my it was so
bad they have like athletes foot I think
so and then like he had to actually tell
him like Hey next time when you come you
got to leave your socks on cuz we didn't
afterwards we didn't know what was
happening like what what is that smell
and he was like Lysa mopping that [__]
and then when one day when you walked to
the bathroom we smelled the trail and
then we put our nose to the [__]
floor and we're like oh [__] there it is
we got him did you bounce
like like a cat we both went one of
these like oh [__] your legs go up like
trying to dodge a punch oh I almost
vomited dude it was so bad and those are
the [__]
that shower in the gym shower without
shoes on dude yeah I think he probably
just had like athletes foot or something
people get like fungus on their feet
from oh it's like a serious thing they
need to just shower and bleach I
think but that's dangerous on us cut him
off if we shared that [__] floor with
bare feet we could have got fungus feet
cuz of him you know godamn I'm always
looking at people's feet and I'm like oh
bro get out of here oh yeah it's in
front of you right when you do JJ yeah
I'm just like oh dude get [__] did
you kiss it sometimes oo that's a
strategy I love that this went from uh
which job taught you the most to uh how
do you tell people blame subin from for
having such a good
[Music]
story